انت عرفت للاصابه في الاحتجاجات في ايران
فمن الافضل لك ان لا تلجا لاي مستشفى او
صيدليه ان كنت تريد العوده الى منزلك
سالما هي نصيحه يتبعها المحتاجون في ايران
والسبب هو ان المستشفيات والصيدليات ايضا
اصبحت اشبه بمخافر الشرطه حيث ينتشر فيها
رجال الامن والمخبر الموضوع لم يروق
للاطباء انفسهم حيث بادر البعض منهم الى
تنظيم وقفه احتجاجيه امام المجلس الطبي
اعتراضا على وجود قوه الامن في المستشفيات
فضلا عن اعتقال البعض منهم وترهيبهم
الموضوع بلغ حد التخلي عن اداء الواجب
المهني خوفا من بطش قوات الامانه ولان
الحاجه تبرر الوسيله فان العديد من
المحتاجين بداوا باللجوء الى اطباء
بيطريين لعلاجه من اصابتهم وذلك لتمويه
رجال الامن
الاكثر من ذلك فان شراء ضماده من الصيدليه
قد يتحول الى تهمه تعرضك للخطر ولضرر اكبر
من الاصابه نفسها فضمضه قد تتحول الى خيطا
يتبعه رجال الشرطه للكشف عنه هويات
المحتاجين
لكنها غيره اصحاب البذلات البيضاء على
واجبهم الوطني دفعتهم الى انشاء شبكه غير
رسميه على الانترنت لتواصل مع المتظاهرين
المصابين ومحاوله مساعدتهم بعيدا عن
مستشفياتنا انتم هيك حرمتها من طرف رجال
الامن وسام الذهبي العربي